بوتين لمقاتلي فاغنار اسامحكم ولكن بثلاث
شروط وبريجو جان يرد ورغم وعود الكريم
طباخ بوتا لا يزال في ورطه كبيره و واشنطن
تقدم طلبا لبوتينر فاغنر تلحق باسلحه
بوتين النوويه الى بيلاروسيا فما هو الهدف
والاستخبارات الامريكيه تطالب بريجوجان
بسته مليارات دولار فماذا كان المقابل
والرئيس البولندي يصرخ من خدعه روسيه قد
تصيب بلاده وحده المعارك تزداد اكثر فاكثر
في اوكرانيا وتايوان تشهر سيف التحدي امام
بيكين واسرائيل توسع رقعتها في فلسطين
والمقاومه تتوعد برد قوي وفي السودان عيد
وهدنه واشتباكات في ان واحد
خدعه الانقضاء
في الارجاء ولا الصوت يعلو فوق صوت
تداعيات التمرد فهنا الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين يؤكد بان التمرد المسلح
كان سيتم انهائه بكل الاحوال لكنهم عملوا
على منع سفك الدماء فيما قال رئيس
بيلاروسيا الكسندر لوكاشينكو ان اي احتمال
الانهيار روسيا يعني انهيار بيلاروسيا
ايضا مضيفا واعطيت الاوامر للجيش بالتاهب
وقت التمرد لنعد للوراء قليلا الى احداث
التمرد حيث صرح قائد قوات احمد الخاصه
الشيشانيه ابتي على ان الاوامر التي صدرت
من قبل الاداره الروسيه بعدم اطلاق النار
على متمرد فاغنار منعت اراقه دماء الاخوه
الروس بينما افادت قناه سي ان ان
الاستخبارات الامريكيه قد جمعت معلومات
مفصله ودقيقه عن خطط مؤسس شركه فاغنار
العسكريه الخاصه يفجن بريجوجان قبل تمرده
لكنها لم تكشف عنها للحلفاء لكن لماذا
تخفي واشنطن استخبارات مهمه كهذه الذي كان
يخطط له ابناء العم سام لتذهب صحيفه لوس
انجلوس الى ابعد من ذلك وتعترف بان خضع
الاستخبارات الامريكيه واخذ منهم مبلغ سته
فاصله اثنين مليار دولار بحجه التمرد وكما
تشاهدون هذا ما تم نشره في الصحيفه التي
افادت بما ذكرناه وكما يقولها المصريون
خدها الغراب طار لتعلن الخارجيه الامريكيه
ان واشنطن تود ان يتم حل جماعه فاجنر
العسكريه الروسيه وتسليم مؤسسها يافغيني
للولايات المتحده في اقرب وقت الا تستحون
يا هؤلاء اتريدون ان يسلمكم بوتينر بكل
سهوله وقد سارع بضمهم للجيش الروسي ولا
زلنا في اخبار تداعيات التمرد وبعد ان تم
ايقاف بريكوجين وقواته ها هو بريجوجان يحل
في بيلاروسيا ليعود لوكاشينكو ويقول بانه
لا يمنع البيلاروسيين من الانضمام الى
بيلاروسيا بانها اشارات سلبيه للغايه
بالنسبه لبلاده وهناك تعززت المخاوف
الغربيه بتقارير روسيه تحدثت عن انه يجري
بناء اول معسكر لوحدات فاجنر الروسيه في
بيلاروسيا وتحديدا على بعد 200 كيلومتر من
الحدود مع اوكرانيا وبحساب المنطق يثير
تحرك فاجنر هواجس جيراني بيلاروسيا بولندا
وليتوانيا في ظل علاقات متوتره فهل يمثل
انتقال فاجنرلي بيلاروسيا خطرا على دول
الجوار مهلا مهلا لا ننسى ان حدود
بيلاروسيا هي اقرب منطقه لكياف ولا ننسى
ايضا ان القوات الاوكرانيه تعمل بشكل
مستمر لانشاء مناورات عسكريه على الحدود
البيلاروسيه متخ من هجومي بيلاروسيا على
كييف فهل حدثت هذه المسرحيه كامله من اجل
الهجوم والسيطره على العاصمه الاوكرانيه
ليتم انهاء الحرب وباسرع وقت ممكن
وكالعاده نحن لا ناتي بشيء من مخيلاتنا بل
نستند الى مصادر موثوق اذا بحسابات
الجغرافيا يعتبر وجود فاغنر في بيلاروسيا
تهديدا مباشرا للعاصمه الاوكرانيه
وبحسابات المنطق يثير تحرك فاجنر
هواجساجيراني بيلاروسيا بولندا وليتوانيا
في ظل علاقات متوتره ولكن من جهه اخرى عاد
الرئيس الروسي ليصف مقاتل فاغنر بالوطنيين
الذين تم استغلالهم مؤكدا السماح لمن يرغب
منهم بمتابعه الخدمه في وزاره الدفاع او
العوده الى الحياه المدنيه او الرحيل الى
بيلاروسيا اما وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
فاعلنت انها تستعد لتسلم الاسلحه الثقيله
من مجموعه فاغنار العسكريه
للجيش الروسي ويتزامن ذلك مع غلق
التحقيقات الجنائيه ضد زعيم فاجنر
من قبل جهاز الامن الفيدرالي الروسي ورغم
ذلك فان صحيفه كيميار سانت الروسيه تقول
ان جهاز الامن الاتحادي الروسي لا يزال
يجري تحقيقات حول
رئيس مجموعه باجنار العسكريه الخاصه بتهمه
التدبير تمرد مسلح
يخرجان عن صمته مؤكدا ان الزحف الى موسكو
بدا بسبب الظلم الذي تعرضت له مجموعته
مشيرا الى انه كان هناك قرار بحل المجموعه
في الاول من يوليو لتاتي هنا الردود
الغربيه فالرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن يقول
ان بلاده لا علاقه لها بما يحدث في روسيا
ولن تتدخل واضاف انه اتفق مع الحلفاء على
عدم اعطاء الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
اي عذر لالقاء اللوم على دول النيتو فيما
يحدث في روسيا على حد تعبيره على الطرف
الاخر
مسؤول العلاقات الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف انما حدث في روسيا يضعف
قدرتها العسكريه والنظام السياسي في
البلاد يظهر هشاشه كبيره وهذا احد اكبر
تداعيات الحرب على اوكرانيا حسب تعبير ومن
اجواء التمرد الى رائحه البارود واصوات
الضجيج الاسلحه حيث تشهد اوكرانيا
اشتباكات الضاريه في محور باخماط بينما
تدفع بقواتها في محاوله لاستعاده السيطره
على المدينه التي فقدتها منذ اكثر من شهر
لقوه فيغنار فيما يعلن الجيش الروسي تصديه
لعشر هجمات في انحاء
ليعلن وزير الدفاع الاوكراني اليكسيري
زينيكوف ان بلاده لم تبدا هجومها المضاد
بعد مضيفا انهم ما زالوا في مرحله الاعداد
فقط
الاحداث والتطورات
في تصعيد غير مسبوق اكد التايوان ان جيشها
سيهاجم السفن وطائرات الحربيه الصينيه في
عمل الدفاعي اذا تم رصدها داخل المياه
الاقليميه لتايوان والتي تبلغ 12 ميلا
بحريا بحسب موقع فوق ستايوان صادق المجلس
الاعلى للتخطيط والبناء التابع للحكومه
الاسرائيليه على اقرار مشاريع لبناء ما
يزيد على 56 وحده استيطانيه جديده في
الضفه الغربيه لتدين الجهات الرسميه
الفلسطينيه المشاريع الاستيطانيه
واعتبرتها لاعبا بالنار الى السودان حيث
اعلن قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
ديجلو حميدتي عن هدنه في البلاد من جانب
واحد لمده يومين بمناسبه عيد الاضحى وبرغم
ذلك فقط تم سماع اصوات اطلاق نار متقطع من
اسلحه ثقيله جنوب ام درمان وغرب الخرطوم
بعد ساعات من اعلان الهدنه
[موسيقى]